Grant has convinced Athena to help him out with some of the the Gleaming
Glasses business stuff. He's given her yet another new equation, that he says
is going to describe the profit the company will make, if he invests x
thousands of dollars in advertising. So we have P of x equals x cubed minus 20
x squared plus 118 x minus 164. Grant wants to figure out how much money he
needs to spend on advertising to make some sort of profit, but he also wants to
avoid spending too much money, so much that it would drain all of his profit
away. In other words, Athena needs to figure out, for what values of x does
this equation P of x equals 0. In other words, Athena is looking for routes of
this function. We're not quite ready to help her answer this question yet
though. Let's backtrack for a second. First off, can you tell me what the
minimum number of real zeros this function has to have is? Think critically
about what kind of polynomial this is.